[Music]
as i started speaking
what was the first thing you noticed
about me
was it my charming smile
my charismatic personality
or
was it my accent
having lived in the u.s now for almost
three years
i realized that for a lot of people it
is my accent
i come from pakistan
which is why i have an unmistakable
south asian accent
i've been fascinated by accidents for
many years
first because well we all have one
second
i feel strongly about how a person's
unique accent can trigger people's
conscious and unconscious biases
and lead to accident discrimination
research has shown that we are less
likely to believe something if it is
said with a foreign accent
these negative judgments are the result
of the additional effort that our brains
must make to process foreign speech
our brains then shift the blame for this
additional effort onto the truthfulness
of the speaker
and it can trigger frustration
about a year ago i was on the phone with
my health insurance company for some
information i needed before an upcoming
trip
i had been on the call for almost an
hour
hopping from one collagen to another
without any solution to my problem
i was becoming more and more impatient
i was then redirected for the fourth
time
and as the new college agent started
speaking
i instantly noticed a distinct east
asian accent
perhaps chinese or korean
and i exploded internally
i don't need this accent right now
i didn't say this to her of course
but that's what i thought
my frustration was caused by my complete
inability to understand anything she was
saying
and then i stopped
at that point it hit me
i was doing exactly what i've been so
strongly opposed to
i was allowing someone's accent
to influence how i saw them
how i listened to them
how i treated them
that day
i was able to name what i felt deeply
about for many years
accent empathy
i define accent empathy as thinking
deeper
about how a person's unique accent is a
manifestation of their lived experience
of their cultural identity
of their humanity
growing up in pakistan i saw firsthand
how perfecting your english proficiency
was seen as much more than just language
acquisition
it was a symbol of status of ability of
sophistication
this is the legacy of 200 years of
british colonialism
mastery of spoken english was what
separated the colonial masters from
their indian subjects
this gave rise to the brown sahabs
indians who yearned to imitate the
british in language stress or lifestyle
because doing so conferred patronage
from the colonial government
even years after the british left the
indian subcontinent
this english-centered indoctrination was
still alive and well
i grew up seeing adults and children
giggle at and even openly insult people
who spoke broken english or
mispronounced an english word
and the opposite was also true
speaking fluent english with perfect
pronunciation and good accents gave you
prestige
high school debate coach once said to
our entire team
all of you need to fix your accent
except mansoor
i'll be like if i said i didn't feel
immense pride at that point
it may seem to be misplaced pride in
retrospect
but then
in that moment
my pride was real
yet this reinforced within me a certain
toxic complex
and insecurity
i had to protect my accent
as i traveled to places outside of
pakistan
i began to realize that
mastery of a language or accent is not a
sign of competence
i began to accept my accent as part of
who i am
of my identity
then i came to the u.s
and suddenly found myself in the odd
position of the guy with the different
foreign accent
sometimes
when i spoke in zoo meetings
i was met with complete silence
the group
all native english speakers
would move on to speaking amongst
themselves
why was this happening
did they disagree with the substance of
what i'd said
was it zoom fatigue
was it my accent
i could only speculate
but this did take a toll on me
i felt overlooked
dismissed
invisible
fortunately for me by this stage of my
life i genuinely began to cherish my
unique accent
i'm not making a political statement of
any sort
i truly cherish my pakistani accent as a
symbol of my life journey and my
identity
i value it as an expression of love
for my family
my grandparents
my home
but accident discrimination is real
according to research at curtin
university in australia
there's a hierarchy that places american
british and australian english accents
at the top
views european accented english as cute
or stylish
but asian or african accents as ugly and
unpleasant
the uk
is known to view specific accents as
working class versus sophisticated
former british prime minister margaret
thatcher had to lose the lincolnshire
accent to sound more posh
in the u.s the story is a bit more
nuanced
laura rivera in her book pedigree
writes that accents play a role in
shaping recruitment at elite firms
according to rivera
interviewers frequently questioned
the polish of foreign students of all
races
complaining
that most candidates actions made them
difficult to understand
exceptions
were those with pure british
german or scandinavian accents
this is the accent hierarchy at work
there's also anti-black racism in
linguistics
something that even former first lady
michelle obama had to contend with
and she's a harvard educated lawyer
but i believe that we owe it to
ourselves
and to each other
to put in that little extra effort
to move beyond any cognitive and
intellectual laziness that might be
stifling us
so the next time you find yourself
struggling to engage with someone having
an unfamiliar accent
i challenge you to pause
take a deep breath
ask yourself why am i having such a
reflexive reaction
is it just because the accident is
different from my own
think about what your accent says about
you
your family your festivals
your aspirations your struggles
your identity
do you really want to rob someone of the
same
just so you can save a few seconds of
mental energy
that
to me is accent empathy in action
and if we truly aspire to change lives
and change organizations in an
increasingly interconnected world we
need access empathy
thank you
[Music]
you